hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to hell's prison gmod [ __ ]
Mac with yamimash that's not potato
balls that's actually yamimash hey guys
I'm potato balls nice to meet you you're
not potato balls you're yamimash I
better who this young MSU speak of is
mmm
you will just made up I don't know your
beard is kind of weird you're building
up some muscle there iced tea you're
looking good I know I'm just trying to
get muscly uh-huh anyway five years
after the incident that happened in
Hell's Resort
oh is this a sequel the health resort
apparently so yeah I love it out that
was a good one right yeah that was a
great one yes okay I'm gonna get a good
one
rumors of haunted house spread angry mob
burned the Erie Motel thinking it would
stop the evil that was not the case of
group of young students you went into an
old band in prison that was mere the
burnt down resort the door behind them
closing now they must fight their way
out okay Zima God mode is off players
hurt players should be off oh no Adam
why do we would we not want to hurt each
other and no clip is on really I I'm
fine now you kill me every single time
you play this you're a liar
how many times you shoot me with a
pistol last time ah a lot I don't have
any weapons I can't shoot you yeah okay
anyway let's just go this map contains
jump scares and loud noises my favorite
a lot the button hasn't worked right
makes her god mode is on god mode is on
really huh and they just tell you to
turn that off yeah they did he says if
the button on the right is not working
so adverse it's okay here we go yeah
come on work baby yeah awesome we died
and that's the end of the month
oh god that was fantastic
Howsam oh oh oh you're inside me oh god
something crazy
oh you're in very clear with 60% how
good you piece of [ __ ] why
though that chart is save us oh you
tried to kill me I'm hang on this I
would never kill you my look a light you
can trust me yeah you very much but yeah
okay so now you sumbitch go first
hey look hey B why huh something wrong
with this level Oh a EO a
I know a a ye ji AE you for so much
doesn't know their alphabet around here
okay so we got a punch the buttons in
order wait okay please in the door do
not uh do not attempt unlocking it
uh-huh I'm going in the code is two six
four one yeah you you press that in I'll
just step right six four one okay ah
come on
I wasn't easy puzzle wait huh hmm Oh -
Tommy how do we put okay oh that's how
for that's an H
oh is that nature of for I can't tell
huh that's it for was it H is this might
be an age you never know okay so there's
a puzzle and usually we don't do too
well with these puzzles we don't last
very long doing these before one of us
well youichi i do not see what are you
talking about
Oh what I bruise right are you talking
about I'm gonna like go back to an the
obvious you cheer now I'm gonna like
just unlisting and comment with it oh
wait a minute there are numbers by the
doors is okay it's two 641 that means
that means uh E is too doughy E
um let me try to get this out for you MA
eh ah eh hy e 8y eh eh y eh
how are you trying to say H Y hey hey oh
eh oh eh oh yeah me first
all right hmm I prepare for that mark
careful wait what you want you press the
button ah first of all I wasn't a good
idea leave now
it hungers what hunger well I don't know
I'm just going that how's it what Oh
boom I mean he'll that's probably not
good
Oh got a gal a you know why killed me
cuz I was low on health you son of a
[ __ ] well why you waited me I didn't do
anything you did it okay MA
there we go good job on it thank you
now don't use a strong as me my have
survived that well we can't all be as
buff and tough as you there yamimash oh
yeah I got this damn oh no get on my way
uh-uh
I'm stuck ha ha ha ha god dammit Yama's
yours ok
that's what [ __ ] got him huh ok enjoy
such did you see that teal I flew up
above the screen
where's it are you what oh hey hey you
didn't see that you you are you flew
look through the vent I didn't see that
I didn't see anything else besides that
huh-oh gonna step outside they will come
Oh will they ponies Oh God
ponies please don't start that debecker
Oh God Oh outside did you not read the
warning whoa oh hello 1 hp ha ha that is
the poison headcrab need to kill that
he's been biting me
ok now we're outside was that a good
thing or a bad thing
well there's nothing else we can do so
I'll take it as a good thing
oh is that God nothing just goober to me
yes I'm a hit me too well it's a green
yeah hmm the red grapes gun okay a big
ol big old key on your left okay
ah joking so useless oh I've got a I got
a normal machine gun but Jesus all I
have is a shotgun in the crowbar
well the shotguns not awful and I'm
officially out of ammo hey I got the key
though it's good right yeah I'm just
gonna back up some more doors and then
we can have a nice tea party if you want
laughs yeah me me huh the voices in your
head
ha voices in my head what about the
voices in your head yeah listen to the
Mac they're telling you to do evil evil
thing you see that light and I don't
know what you're on about
mm-hmm I think you're seeing things
maybe I'm going a little crazy there but
I push them you turn the lights on nice
I didn't I didn't yeah laughing second
can I come in
sit oh [ __ ] hell look at rain rain
well then ooh there's a pentagram over
there we'll boil the choo-choo Express
no no no dick you should just step in
them alone I wanna let me in let me add
it let me add it
what's whew I swim what the [ __ ]
goddamn baby
oh gee fence all right this is your own
doing by my good thing
Oh No ha ha ha well Sean oh Jesus I'm on
my way
don't die holding on these things coming
yes not so bad you just gotta learn to
love them embrace them they don't even
have a vagina oh that's not what I meant
by embrace'
but you knew whatever your free loving
spirit wants to do to be fair I like
when they look like that
when they have vaginas hey come on that
freaking like that house I don't know
your type they're young - new a little
dead you know they're not there were a
lot of them I think you should have just
let's just close the door and lock him
in there good
that room is not worth the trouble it's
too much hassle for so I think I found
your big banana there oh come in there
it's all pink and squishy ha ha don't be
gross yamimash why aren't you on side ok
ok nothing our page yes sir
what is he doing I think he wanted them
to forget him suffer first-hand glimpse
of the vagina yeah I think you wanted to
have a little fun and he had a little
too much fun of you know what I mean a
little taste a little bite huh ah
another puzzle oh damn it I smell your
fear feed me nothing see the joy pumping
and you remember that thing when booze
on the hell's Rizzoli masu no what is
that
thank you what is this day me anyway ah
it it's a caution where your respect
respirator I don't care what it said
Yami you should have read the cautions
niemelä look at me die
you son of a [ __ ] look why don't you go
in there a second I thought it'd be done
love Mars all these if you walk in here
the doors gonna close ah cry are you
making fun of me on me mash are you
making fun of me okay well I mean I
don't know why you would either think
I'm pretty fine to me okay I heard a
thunk II thunk funky pop what the hell
Jesus did you see that well some black
shadow thing yeah well then I got him it
do you watch the jump scares like Jesus
Christ [ __ ] boy too much shooting in
this one sorry I hit you
I feel like shooting me please sorry
just kill him man I'm like out of ammo
I'm trying to reload here I thought you
just died didn't you get more ammo yeah
I got more ammo now yeah okay I was just
reloading I ran out in my clip and I had
to relearn into changes the sugars sucks
for reloading mmm
I wasn't of a pentagram oh I wonder if
it's good oh here's some more ammo okay
I took it all oh you got the or you go
dummy bad what the what the how you just
ported your teleported back there I just
had a picture of the girl from The
Exorcist flying my screen did it scare
you did you not get that
no I didn't to be fair I would say scare
me but my sound really needs to be
turned up hello
Oh once I'm telling my sound ugh once
you protect me for a second I really
don't like I will that's far too low
okay okay that's mean that's much better
it's better now I should be most area
Stu much scarier I guess since you're
not recording me it don't matter
yeah it's fine it's fine okay carrying
gone these cells have numbers on my one
of them did it
oh here's the puzzle Ruthie yeah well
not 25 on it um we have a look around
here 25 and the other side seem to have
any numbers okay so maybe this section
who's here big maybe there's some more
numbers over here possibly yes
this isn't a pentagram this is a
hexagram uh-huh yeah well you know same
thing right nut Quay
okay so 25 and then what else do we need
to know if we find any more numbers then
I'm sure we'll have those together and
kapowee
and kapowee oo3 2503
ah or it could be I 325 not it 2503 huh
ah no 325 0-3 25 yeah hmm and thanks to
my brilliant minds it didn't work oh um
there's more over here more now Rocco
771 I think that yeah 2500 371 I could
be a fall I don't under I am watching ha
it's an eye I am watching ha ha huh and
it's another Isis like I am watching I
you know it's like slang no no I don't
think I can okay so 7 103 25 ah come on
try e o 371 2503
honey 125 ah with Mike where's my
goddamn gravity that was one more
variation of that I'm just trying to
really wonder 2500 you do that I'm gonna
look around for me on one nope
uh-oh oh this is quite the registration
Deveney 1 1 500 370 145 let us through
follow the hidden steps alone trust no
one
what we know do me not go in this room
where are you not come here
well hey wait where are you um
but you go wait wait hey hey hey okay I
don't know if we were in this room so
you may as well give it a go just right
right in oh oh oh oh you I try trust you
do you was it huh this is a crate yeah
but for you can't break it's too strong
of a metal fine but what's the point of
this follow this hidden steps trust
alone trust
okay I'll meet you too I'll leave you to
it go on you're alone now I mean I think
there's actually a thing look on the
floor the steps on the floor what what
are you talking about if you look on the
floor as footprints
Oh follow those Oh what what do they
mean I don't notice a puzzle go towards
the box
uh-huh what is anything happening in
there no huh nothing's happening well
this was a disappointment
this is stupid this whole game is stupid
it was great before these were our
footprints that we just put in it while
he was walking in it no I don't think
that's it no oh how was the that was it
uh discipline that was a waste of time
we got to figure out these number
combination
Oh God numbers ah no wonder I failed
math did you oh yeah there's a room of
death okay I got a satisfactory grade so
that's good enough I don't know what
that means it's all British it's all
like yeah you did okay he's a hint here
that something's happening
am watching and there their eyes over
there wait go to go to that room and see
what if the eyes are looking at
something
those eyes over there what I'll go back
to near the beginning through the vent
read the vent yeah through the vent
pull those eyes over there it says I am
watching oh I see what you're saying and
then the eyes are looking at something
on the far wall
he trashed the pool